l'allemagne a capitulé l'armistice est
signé
certes mais ce n'est qu'un cessez le feu
rappel cette exposition composée d'une
trentaine de caricatures et dessins de
presse
il faudra attendre le 28 juin 1919 pour
que le traité de versailles met fin à la
première guerre mondiale
une date qui n'a pas provoqué à l'époque
un enthousiasme débordant
parmi les euréliens et le français le
souci c'est de manger
et puis on a aussi le souci dans
beaucoup de familles sont des familles
endeuillées et donc faire la fête c'est
pas tellement le rove leur souci
primordial
le traité et les négociations qui l'ont
entouré sont pourtant les choux gras des
caricaturistes français et allemand bien
qu ancien ennemi
ils pointent dans leur dessein une paix
est extrêmement fragile on peut voir ici
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
français d'abord un gros pavé qui on le
voit ici et grignoter de tout parent non
seulement parler par les allemands mais
également par parler nos alliés qui n'y
trouvent pas leur compte et d'un point
de vue allemand on voit également ce
traité de versailles qui lui n'est pas
n'est pas figurer sous forme sous forme
d'un texte de loi mais par déjà
symbolisée par la colombe de la paix
mais on voit déjà menacé par l'ours
l'ours berlinois qui censé représenter
le peuple peuple allemand cette même
menacé s'explique par la rancoeur des
allemands humilié à qui l'on reprend
l'alsace lorraine comme le montre cette
caricature mais ce traité c'est aussi la
zizanie dans les rangs alliés dès le
début des années 20 les caricatures
montrer à quel point ce traité portait
en lui les germes de la seconde guerre
mondiale